hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast particle size
distribution of cement using laser
diffraction my name is Dean fan from lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
beckman coulter beckman coulter serves a
diverse range of customers in the
industrial market in areas such as
aerospace automobile agriculture
chemicals construction fuels electronics
just as name a few Beckman is a key
supplier to quality control and standard
operating processes with a range of
products in air and liquid particle
counting as well as laser diffraction
for particle size distribution we have a
few important announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the events you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problems through the green
Q&A button lower left I would like now
to introduce today's speaker Edward hast
ever cough is a graduate of the
University of Miami with a BS in
chemistry here's a 43 year veteran of
culture corporation and Beckman Coulter
in the particle characterization
division and started his career as a
chemist in the applications lab
eventually transitioning into project
development and marketing manager roles
he has helped develop the multi sizer
series LS series for laser diffraction
and n for dynamic light scattering
system just to name a few in recent
years Edna moved into the field sales
and is now a sales specialist with 43
years in the particle characterization
industry and has a wealth of application
knowledge across numerous markets I will
now turn it over to Ed for his
communications thank you soon
today as as you mentioned we'll be
discussing that particle sizing of
cement using laser diffraction type
instrumentation and the areas that will
be discussing will be the importance of
particle size analysis for cement rusev
laser diffraction also the ls13 320
which is beckman coulter laser
diffraction system in the importance of
how this is transitioned in the
marketplace will be discussing
flexibility of modules that is to
present samples to the instrumentation
and also quality data comparing to ISO
standards as well as n is p 1 14 srms
114 cube for cement so traditionally
methods used in the cement industry
within Blaine number right notability
major and probably more commonly SIDS
but these only provides a single number
or limited size information about the
cements and what has happened over the
years as cement requirements have high
performance men's have been needed with
more stringent requirements the particle
size distribution information was is
needed in more detail to more properly
control the quality of the cement and
versus its performance desired the
vorlons a complete size distribution has
been increasingly important and so over
the last 20 years or so technology
advances have been moving toward the
laser diffraction type instrumentation
for a variety of reasons that we'll get
to in a moment but one thing you want to
consider is
not all laser diffraction particle size
analyzers are created equal they may be
based on laser diffraction but how you
implement and in design everything from
sample handling to optics will
contribute to the quality of the results
you get this is just a example of some
distributions that are quite can be
quite complicated usually distributions
are not Gaussian or very symmetrical
that could have multiple pink's because
you're typically dealing with lens of
materials that might be being measured
and one of the key things you want to
consider in a instrumentation is that
you can analyze these without prior
knowledge of what the distribution shape
is and so that that's a consideration to
consider when you are looking at
diffraction type instruments now if the
particle sizes are too large you have an
abnormal amount of large particles
present you can get crumbling of your
cement I'm likin left photographs and if
they're too small too many fines you can
get cracking of your cement especially
with temperature changes or pressure or
stress on the on the cement so these are
things you want to try to optimize and
the only way to properly do this is to
have really a detailed particle size
distribution and trying to figure this
out some instrumentation or prior
devices that would only give single
numbers or limited number of channels
like in Syd's now the advantages of
laser diffraction is multi
felted these instruments are quite easy
to use they cover a broad dynamic range
in other words from submicron particles
to usually multiple millimeters so a
couple of thousand microns down to below
a micron they can do this quite fast
typically results can be in one to three
minutes their bouts to be longer
depending on if running liquid systems
the other advantages these type of
instruments are quite reproducible and
also operator independent and the
results there's these kinds of
instrumentation can be run in a dry
state or a liquid suspension such as
alcohols or hexing or some other solvent
that might be desired to run so particle
systems can be dispersed in that or run
in a totally dry state and it's
mentioned above very important is the
operator independent results the
instrument doesn't care usually what
type of who's putting the sample and as
long as it's a representative sample
that's that's really the key for any
particle size analysis a big discussion
on ISO standards iso standard 13 3 20
discusses some key factors that are
important for these are the fraction
that one wants to consider in their
design I saw took these into
consideration so resolution and
sensitivity of the result in other words
you want to be able to resolve different
sizes easily and they are also able to
sense small changes
in a particle system if the distribution
is changing be able to see these readily
reproducibility of course is highly very
important and then accuracy of the
results and we'll discuss these in more
detail rather in the lecture the ls13
320 of course the name ls13 320 comes
from the chapter number for iso standard
mainly because this was the first
instrument truly follow the full
standard the ISO standard and that's
where it was named from LS standing for
light scatter and there's two types of
models in the optical bench we'll get
into a moment in detail but basically
you have what's called a
multi-wavelength optical bench which
allows one if what if if you're running
with liquid based samples can cover 17
nanometers to 2000 Mike runs in a single
scan and then there's the finger wave
length optical bench it has less optics
in it does not have the bottom end
optics and so you're covering point
three seven five microns to 2000 microns
and to ideal modules that that we offer
for that would be ideal for cement if
one was going to want to run in liquid
based systems where you can typically
liquid systems you can control
dispersion a little bit more but that
may not be how the powder is being
utilized and may be utilized in the dry
state but we have the universal liquid
module and then also for doing in a dry
state totally dry state the tornado dry
powder system it will discuss things and
details in a moment
so some key features of the LS and that
one wants to consider and these are of
course benefits for the cement
applications I mentioned earlier about
not wanting to for complex distributions
not wanting to have to input information
about distribution shape we usually
don't know this prior to analyzing the
sample so we have essentially what's
called other modalities we call it where
there's no requirement for operator
input into a distribution shape you
don't need to know the which the is a
bimodal model modal narrow broad multi
peaked you don't have to know anything
about the sample distribution shape to
get the proper the correct answer
secondly on resolution insensitivity the
LS series as what we call a unique
binocular optics so it has a allows us
to pick up a wide range of light scatter
wide angular range that is and we detect
these this wide angular range using a
126 detective diode array and and this
is a very important for given us that
resolution is sensitivity to detect very
subtle changes in distributions that one
might have if the process changes
because you want to know when things
change quickly so you can make
adjustments in your process to keep the
desired particle size on the other side
accuracy and precision it's controlled
by the angular position or knowing the
angles of light scatter you basically
know
22 things about your particle size
distribution we know the angle and you
know the amount of light that's being
scattered due to your particle size
distribution from that information the
particle size distribution is a
calculation converting that light
scatter utilizing leaders on offer a new
theory to get the appropriate and
accurate particle size distribution and
positioning and aligning of of that
system is extremely important and we
have this I'll show a picture of it
later an X pattern low angle detector
that allows us to position and hold
about one micron tolerance on
positioning that laser beam and this
gets us the very accurate and very
precise results so we can good precision
as well as very accurate results and
then lastly use of operation both of
these systems have built-in or you can
create slps or standard operating
procedures and essentially allow a
one-button operation for your particle
size analysis so these instruments can
be used by production people they're not
very complicated to use so the results
are analyzed quite fast and utilizing
this mode and in systems we either
automatically clean themselves if it's a
wet system or be ready for the next
analysis in a short amount of time with
very minimal contact with the computer
also available on the LS is for those
that want to correlate back to screen
sizes or mesh units there's a sip stack
correlation you can use when you want if
you
desired this capability and so we can
individually correlate to individual
screen sizes and you would select the
screens that you use and you can
correlate the results of the LS can give
out the same type of correlation because
you laser diffraction instruments
measure more of the volume of the
particle so when you're sitting you're
measuring the middle dimension of a
particle so you can correlate back to
this size you can apply a correlation
factor in the instruments output to
correlate directly to screens that you
use briefly this is a layout of the
optics in this area here we have the
binocular optics and then our low angle
detector which I'll show picture of in
detail a little bit later the upper
section of the instrument is what we
call pigs optics I'm not going to go
into details of what pigs is all about
it this during this lecture but suffice
to say this allows for the low-end
measurement below half a micron
four-tenths of a micron and down the 17
nanometers for very accurate measurement
and very high resolution measurements
down in that region another sort of
unique feature of this this quote area
here is essentially a spatial filter but
it's a fiber optic cable it's a patented
design of Vecna Coulter's and this
essentially eliminates the need for
about 20 pin holes and lenses and things
that can obviously go out of adjustment
from older design systems and utilizing
this fiber optic cable allows a very
clean signal to be because where you're
trying to create a very clean
no from the laser in a very stable
signal and so this allows for great help
in being able to if one's needed to
actually put a new laser in a system in
the field without any problem brief
leaving two modules that I mentioned the
universal liquid module these are for
running any kind of fluid it can handle
any class new solvent holds
approximately a hundred twenty hundred
twenty five mils of fluid and this is
circulated by a centrifugal custom
design pump designed specifically for
particles handling particles it can work
with aqueous fluids as well but
obviously and cement you're going to be
running solvents if you're going to be
running in the web state and depending
on which optical bench one has you can
tell us either 17 nanometers to 2000 or
point three six and five to two thousand
depending on which bench you have this
module will rinse itself between runs it
can auto the loot in case you've added
too much sample we want to keep a
certain range of obscuration so we can
get light through the sample as they
passed the laser it has built-in
sonication this is an optional item if
one once it and it can also fill from a
built-in pump so it filled from the
container automatically on the dry side
of the amount of st. well one uses is
based primarily on the size distribution
you typically like to add enough power
to run about 20 to 30 seconds they
should give you a very good
representative sample
so that would typically be a runtime and
no matter which bench you have the size
range running dry is going to be 0 point
3 75 microns to 2000 microns and it uses
vacuum only who's like a vacuum cleaner
high quality vacuum cleaner we offer
that's well grounded so you don't have
any static forces or anything like that
and I'll get into its unique design why
it's called tornado in a moment and this
module is designed to disperse the
powders very well and essentially be
ready to operate there's no cleanup when
you run dry because all the powder is
passed through and what gone to vacuum
so you're essentially ready for your
next analysis immediately Universal
liquid module is pictured above the next
to my slides here and essentially in the
center section there is where you would
put your sample you're only needing to
put in a small amount of sample this can
be predisposed outside the instrument or
you can add directly a dry powder or a
suspension already directly to the
module so if you want to prepare the
sample in the module you can do that
since it has built-in sonication you can
control the power and the sonication
time and so forth appropriate to the
material you're going to be analyzing
and what might be part of an SLP this
but I'll be controlled by the computer
you're continually keeping the particles
suspended so you have a homogeneous
mixture and these are going through the
passing the laser beam so we can
definitely
multiple times so we can definitely get
a good picture of what the distribution
like scatter intensity distribution
looks like so we can then calculate the
appropriate particle size most people
are tending to start going into the dry
powder systems because of the teams of
operation there is no sample prep you're
taking the powder directly and get a
representative sample and you're placing
it in a what looks like a small
graduated cylinder and placing that in
the sample module this goes into the
same orientation as the liquid module
fits into the same slot and effectively
the dispersion is going to be controlled
by the vacuum in the flow path and and
also how the dispersion takes place and
I'll show you some schematics in that at
the moment and but one key thing about
this dry powder system is that it
analyzes all the powder that you give it
that's what dictates how long the
instruments going to run so you might
add depending on the distribution a half
a gram to maybe a couple of grams but
again depending on the size distribution
the bigger the particles are we to give
more volume of powder you might have to
run in a short period of time but you're
typically going to add about enough
material to run 20 to 30 seconds but by
analyzing all the powder we eliminate
any sub sampling error any segregation
that could have taken place once it's on
an instrument it doesn't matter because
the instruments going to analyze all the
powder that you gave it this is a little
closer view of the material of the
module and the sample chamber is right
here
you're going to place the sample and a
cuvette and we it has a vortex type
action and this is a patented design
that we created back a number of years
ago and this design we took into
consideration the possible use of
pressure or in vacuum in this and we
worked out this unique system where it
only required a vacuum like from the
vacuum cleaner type device and the
computer controls the exact vacuum that
you put on the system but you can
typically r than a run with about 12
inches of water vacuum the most
applications and basically in detail how
works is you have an up and down
platform that that the sample module is
going is positioned on this platform
rises and lowers you have a fixed
position switch and probe and then the
as the platform Rises the powder starts
swirling around and i'll have another
picture in a moment a little closer of
or text nature that's taking place but
the powder gets pulled up flows through
and down through a measuring cell this
is a laminar flow cell that keeps the
particle stream and a nice tight stream
that laminar flow that's flowing through
it to keep that particle system stream
so it keeps your actually it keeps the
particles in a closed closed stream so
you don't have a lot of spray so there's
essentially your windows and things like
that in this closed chamber essentially
don't get dirty very often so maybe it
once he
year they have to be like down depending
on this human type of powder sect is
going to be dealing with and then out
the vacuum and another closer up what
happens is we create a Vorta sees right
above the surface of the particles as
the platform risers and particles start
going through the instrument the
computer controls at platform that I
mentioned because it wants to control
the feed rate excuse me wants to control
the feed rate so we have a constant set
of particles in front of the beam and
also these vortexes are like little mini
tornadoes so it creates a very high
shear area and so you have high shear
but low velocity so you tend to disperse
the powders very well and and then of
course the low velocity we don't want
them banging it around or hitting any
hardware right angles or anything like
that so for cement it's not quite as
fragile but some applications you could
have fragile particles that might break
if you have too much velocity and this
can happen in pressurized systems where
you are forcing them particles and
they're very high pressure you can tend
to break them but this is a more gentle
way of dispersing the power tackles and
have them float through the instrument
and once once the system has analyzed
everything in the container that
contains the platform everything goes
down to the bottom of the starting
position and you remove the cell
essentially you're ready for the next
sample so
we'll discuss here and show some data
here in a moment the resolution
sensitivity how it affects
reproducibility and accuracy so we'll be
showing some data and some additional
slides here also the results here on 114
too so resolution and sensitivity is
very important as controlled by the
geometry the number the position in
geometry of the detector elements I
mentioned earlier we have 126 that
detector diode array and what you need
to really define who is this raw
intensity data as pictured in the grass
and because what you get is is pictured
in the right there you'll get some
pattern depending on the distribution of
your particles this pattern can vary and
the intensity of these rings in dark
spots can vary and so the better you can
define this distribution of your left of
your light scatter pattern the more
accurate the results can be also the
resolution and be able to determine is
it bimodal mono mode will have three or
four peaks or a little side peak that
might be not visible with some systems
we can we can make these measurements
because of the high number of detectors
in the fact that we read these detectors
simultaneously for the same particles so
we can make a very accurate measurement
here because as I said earlier you know
two things like light intensity as a
function of angle so the better you
position these things and measure these
things the more accurate and precise
your data is going to be this is a
schematic drawing of the low angle
detector array and it forms what we call
an X pattern with the beam dump right in
the center
so right in the center you have your
beam down and that's where you're
aligning the laser tube because that
fixes the position and as i said earlier
to you might have angles as low as or
under point 0 2 degrees and out too far
as 145 but when you're dealing with
particles would say 50 microns in above
these low angle detectors are extremely
important and the ability to align that
laser is very important also the sample
handling of always flowing a
representative powder or if it's in a
liquid system keeping the particles
suspended in homogeneous throughout the
measurement is extremely important as
well as the optics but this allows us to
very easily position the laser beam and
when one does this takes a few seconds
to do an alignment on the instrument the
instrument will automatically do this
periodically so the operator doesn't
have to remember what to do it but this
will ensure very accurate very instant
precise results both the instrument to
instrument so if you're comparing one
plant to another you should be putting
the same results and also within the
same instruments precision and accuracy
is improved by this basic design and
discussing accuracy and I'll show some
results in a moment of course accuracy
is defined as the closeness of a result
to a true accepted value so you're going
to be running controls under standard
stepped up in and I'll show one in a
moment but in the ISO standard
this is defined as being able to do
measure the new 50 medium-sized and be
able to get three measurements and the
deviation should be less than three
percent which is pretty generous by our
standards but from the certified value
and some results that are displayed here
is a Duke standard this one is about one
micron just shown as an example and
looking at the results and and this has
a point three percent so it's ten times
better than what's required by the ISO
standard as an example and then last but
not least when analyzing real cement
utilizing the NIH das RM 114 Q the Miss
values for the standard order
diamond-shaped positions with big using
lines being you have to be within and
now the standards for laser diffraction
instruments and one has to be within the
bloom lines for to be acceptable and so
what we did here is run both the tornado
the dry module and the universal liquid
module and we in the dry module is they
dotted under the dash red line and the
universal liquid module is the smaller
redox and we can see they're well within
the error bars of the standard itself
and and so this shows quite good
agreement between both wet and dry
so as long as you can and cement
typically disperse it's pretty well both
in a wet and dry state so when things
are there's no problem with dispersion
or stickiness of materials wet and dry
should agree with each other similarly
like this and this shows the quality of
data you can expect from from the LS for
running Smiths and that's pretty much my
talk on be available for questions here
at moment if you have additional
questions that come up and think about
things later I've got an email address
for dave dunham will be glad to take
questions and get answers back to you
also for those that might be attending
the word of concrete in Las Vegas this
coming week we will have a booth there
in 71 is our booth number you'll be
there and be glad to answer any
technical questions also we'll have a
live we'll have a live LS so if you have
any sample will be glad to run one or
two samples for you and get your results
and I thank you very much well thank you
very much for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience of how to
submit questions you could submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window will try to
answer as many as we can now while the
questions are coming in we would like to
conduct a poll asking how likely are you
to recommend this webinar to a colleague
please respond with your answer on a
scale of one to five with one being not
likely at all and five being extremely
likely okay and our first question is
can you bring one of these systems to my
location for demonstrations yes we can
most all the sales reps and particle
characterization have a demo unit and
they can can certainly be arranged to
come in and do a demonstration at your
plant site also available if you wish is
you can submit samples to our
applications lab and we glad to run them
in our lab and get you the results right
back and this is at a no charge of
course for lab samples and of course
we'll be glad to show you the LS in
doing a sample at your site that's great
our next question Miguel asks what what
is the life of the sensor um typically
lasers these are solid state lasers so
they can run depending on its use of its
point if your operational 24 hours a day
or within your operational 24 hours a
day you're probably talking eight to ten
years and if you're going to be running
just one or two shifts that could be
someone a little bit longer I usually
don't see or hear about lasers being
replaced maybe 12 years out 14 years out
so last a long time and you mentioned
the lab analysis and one viewer asked
how do you submit a free lab analysis um
that's done that can be done through our
website you can go to particle
characterization and access it through
there for submitting particles
you can call up and discuss your need
with the your local salesperson particle
characterization sales rep and he can
give you the exact details for
submitting a sample of the first sample
to run at no charge and you know and so
that can be arranged a lot of your
communication they all done through the
web as far as downloading the
application and application form for the
lab and and then it gives you details of
where to send it and so forth the rules
are going to be running our Miami lab
where these instruments are manufactured
or our grants pass oregon lab for those
that might be on the west coast a little
closer so those are two two locations
for laboratories that's great those
resources another person asks how many
samples can I run in a day if you're
running dry uh that's going to be the
quickest way since you're not having to
rinse the module your typical analysis
time might be between a minute to a
minute and a half per sample so you can
run in an hour you're going to you could
run 40 samples in an hour running dry if
you're constantly ready you know you
have samples available and ready to feed
you can fill up these little cups you
get 10 cups with the instrument and you
can just constantly feed in the
instrument the data is automatically
being saved so it's a sponsor's you're
almost as fast as that you can feed
samples to it until it to operate so
it's it's it's not difficult to do a
very high number in a day an eight-hour
day so you know you're probably talking
in the area maxing max allan about 30 to
40 cm
both 45 samples an hour wow that's great
we have a lot of people who are
interested in the lab analysis so
beckman coulter will send out a sample
analysis link as a follow-up to this
webinar and you might be able to see
this link and as it pops up right now
okay so if we have no more questions
then I would like to pass the control
back to end and see if you have any last
comments for the audience I wish to
thank everybody for attending and for
those that are going to be in Las Vegas
next week look forward I will be there
so look forward to meeting meeting you
and as I said we'll have several
technical people there so be glad to
answer additional questions that might
come up and please don't hesitate to
email dave dunham if you think of some
questions later talk to some associates
and questions come up later be glad to
follow up answering them then thank you
all very much well I'm sorry we I see
some more questions coming in and since
we have some more time let's go through
them so another person asked how does
the auto race work I'd rather rinse as
computer control the module has a high
level a top level level sensor optical
level sensor so we drain and fill the
module three times or this is actually
selectable by the operator submit wrench
is pretty easily and in cement
components so typically you would need
no more than about three rinses of your
module in other words a fill and drain
and the computer controls this speed of
filling and draining and this opera
patient takes about a minute and a half
between samples to to actually rinse the
module and then fill it with clean fluid
so you're ready to add another sample
and run another sample but it's quite
automatic and and as I mentioned during
the lecture be the universal liquid
module has a built-in pump so it's
drawing fluid from a source so this can
be a container of 5 gallon container or
a gallon bottle of sitting on the
ownership next to the instrument or
underneath the instrument if it's a five
gallon container it can draw it up from
the floor so it has a very good
diaphragm type pump that pulled clean
fluid up for rinsing purposes and then
it's going to go into a drain container
since this is a solving you don't want
to dump it down the drain and that drain
container also has level sensors so when
it gets full it will stop the ability to
keep adding fluid to it so you don't
have any overflow and it's time to drain
your the rinse container are they waste
container and that comes with the
instrument the module we have another
viewer asked to the tornado overcome the
effects of trace amounts of liquid in
the dry powder samples of having
particles stick together such as oil or
fake water vapor um part of that's going
to be dictated by the how much water
vapor we might have and what I mean by
that is obviously you'd like it dry but
definitely a few percent moisture can be
convened a present and it can disperse
that it
it's one of those things you probably
want to try and compare it to running it
in a wet state what state you have more
control over your dispersion you can
Sonic gate you can let so you can add
chemical dispersants usually not so much
required chemical dispersants when
you're running in solvents but the tide
can overcome quite a bit but it's a kind
of thing you'd have to test to see what
the upper limit especially if it's an
oil contaminate I think you mentioned
oil contamination that's going to be a
little more stickier than something that
might be dry but it does overcome
moisture but there are limits and it's
the kind of thing that you'd want to
test but if you're doing dry fitting if
you're doing sipping already when the
tornado can be the same you know can do
those kinds of samples if you're not
having a problem doing swimming the
tornado is not going to have a problem
that's great well once again I would
like to thank ed so much for his
presentation that was very informative
and we had some great questions today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through July of 2016 you will
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay and we invite you to afford
that announcement to your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event see
you next time and bye everyone but